- Well, first concerts
provide indelible memories.
You don't say indelible enough guys,
memories for all of us.
And just check this out.
- I know we all have great
memories of our first concerts
that we all went to.
I know I do.
- And my very first Heart
show was my first concert
October 21st, 1978.
- Puff Daddy, like not
P. Diddy, but Puff Daddy.
- New Kids on the Block.
- [Kelly] Oh, I gonna say a boy band.
Okay, okay.
- At Dodger stadium.
- Oh my gosh.
- [Audience Member] Yeah.
- I went to a Backstreet Boys concert
and I threw up on the first song
because the girls were so loud.
They were screaming so loud.
I don't know how that equaled
out to me throwing up, but.
- It's overwhelming.
- I know it happened though.
- I heard that your first ever
concert was pretty amazing.
You wanna tell everybody who that was?
- First ever?
Oh, what a come around
moment with The Jackson 5.
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
- Yes.
- [Kelly] Somebody told me that.
Cause I always ask.
Cause obviously I'm a musician.
So I always ask like when people go see
and that's your first concert?
- Yes, had our little, you know,
bolero jacket and hot pants
and Samson and Delilah sandals.
(Kelly laughing)
And I swear, they looked right at me
and sang the song and it was just great.
- Well, I just can't say it enough.
It's a very rad first concert.
(audience cheering)
- Your dad of course is Phil Collins,
which is incredible to
us and normal for you.
(audience cheering)
But it's just a really
cool thing for a musician.
But what was your first concert?
Like other than obviously your dad's.
- The first concert I,
it was NSYNC.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
Did he get you like,
did he hook you up?
- [Lily] I, it was, it was a hookup,
but it was really like, I just.
- [Kelly] It's a hookup.
You're in a picture with them.
Wait, I just saw the picture.
They were babies.
That's like one of their
first tours, maybe.
- You know what was even crazier is
you know who opened for them,
that no one knew who she was?
Britney Spears.
- What?
(audience gasping)
- Your dad totally hooked you up.
- Honest. He hooked, he
hooked up the opening act too.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I remember sitting in the
audience and they were like
oh, and please welcome the
opening act, Britney Spears.
And everyone's like,
who's, what, who's Britney Spears?
And she came on and did
Hit Me Baby One More Time
and everyone's like, well, she's good.
(audience laughter)
- She's good, she's gonna make it.
- It was wild.
- You were my first concert
I ever went to, in my life.
- [Kelly] Oh, really?
- Yeah.
- You were young.
- How old were you?
- I had to be seven or eight,
- Oh wow.
and it was me and my mom and my sisters.
And I still have the
poster from your concert.
It was,
The Breakaway Days,
which I still listen to
when I'm on airplanes and I cry.
So it's great.
(Kelly laughing)
But yeah, you're just such
a, such an inspiration to me.
- Oh, that's so kind.
What were your first concerts,
like your experience since
you love music so much?
- My, my first concert, I
was invited to this concert
of a band that I didn't know.
- You already feel,
you already feel like a loser?
- I'm apologizing for it.
- But no, but it is like
since you're asking my first concert,
I was like, yeah sure I'll go.
The band was The Hooters.
Does it, do you remember this band?
- Is it like the band for the restaurant?
Like the wings?
- No. No, no, no, no.
Okay.
Great, valid question.
- [Kelly] Valid.
- But they were like kind of,
they had like a couple of hits
in the late eighties, I think.
- [Kelly] Oh. What was yours?
- [Randall Park] My first
concert was very cool.
- What was it?
- I was a kid,
- Oh!
but when Harry Met Sally had come out
I was obsessed with that movie
and the music in the movie.
- And Harry Connick Jr. did
a big part of the soundtrack.
- He's great.
- Yeah.
And I just, we would just
love the soundtrack so much.
And me and a friend, found
out he was playing in Vegas.
We, we grew up in L.A.
And I begged my dad to, to
take us there, get us to
- You begged your dad to take you?
(Kelly laughing)
- And he drove me and my friend to Vegas.
And we just.
- Your dad took you to
Vegas to see a show?
- [Park] Yeah.
- You have a cool dad.
- Very cool of him, yeah.
- Okay. Usually it's
like a pop band, like boy
like its just like a
usually different scenario.
- What are you saying,
what are you trying to say?
- No, I just mean, usually
it was like, you were
you had a very sophisticated
musical palette.
- [Park] There you go, there you go.
- Yeah, yeah, I got there, I got there.
- How old were you?
- Gosh, I must, maybe like
early high school maybe.
- I just mean like, people would be like,
can you take me to Janet Jackson?
Can you take me?
And you were like, please
- Like, can you take me,
Harry, Harry Connick Jr.
- He's amazing.
- And after that.
- I just love him, as a
kid, it was different.
- Like, can we go to the LA Phil?
I really want,
(Kelly and Park laughing)
- Please, please.
- [Ed Helms] They're
doing a Mozart special.
- They are playing Vivaldi
Four Seasons and I must see it.
- [Park] (laughs) I wanna
hear it, yeah, yeah.